fans please direct your attention to the
court where the Indiana Pacers would
like to recognize relita hills from the
Julian Center ronita is a survivor of
brutal domestic violence and currently
serves as an advocate at the Julian
Center concentrating her efforts in our
community working to help young people
who are at risk or who are victims of
violence and ronita as a special
surprise please direct your attention to
the center scoreboard for a message from
Victor Oladipo hey ronita is Victor
Oladipo from the Indiana Pacers last
season I won the Most Improved Player
for the NBA Inc here and they gave me
this nice ride I've heard part of your
story and I think you're an inspiration
to so many people and your survivor I
love giving back to the community of
Indianapolis so surprised this car is
actually for you my friend boomer is
coming to see you to give you the keys
I'll see you tonight after the game
peace
[Applause]
congratulations ronita hills from the
Julian Center
[Music]
[Music]